اعطت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الامان
لهؤلاء المواطنين الذين يقتنون بهذه
المنازل قبل انسحابها من هذه المنطقه
بالتحديد وهي منطقه ابو الامين ثم القت
عليهم برميلا متفجرا ما ادى الى ارتقاء
العشرات الشهداء في هذه المنطقه انتشلوا
هنا قرابه ال5 شهيدا ولا يزال الكثير منهم
تحت الانقاد في هذه المنازل المدمره قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ايضا لا تزال تتواجد
في هذا في هذه المنطقه على بعد 100 متر
تقريبا من مفترق ابو الامير وبالتحديد في
منطقه مسجد التقوى وتطلق الرصاص على كل من
يحاول ان يتجاوز هذا الشارع الذي يظهر في
الصوره او هذا المفترق هنا الدمار واسع في
هذا المكان وعلى مد البصر بعد ان دمرته
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بصوره
متعمده يعني هذه هذه منطقه ابو الامين كما
تشاهدون وهي اقرب نقطه مع قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
الان كما تشاهدون تدور
اقه
بالتحديد
المنقه دي بالكم دي
[موسيقى]
بالكم
الفلسطيني كما تشاهدون الان دفن الشهداء
في المنزل الذي في المنزل المستهدف ايضا
احد المنازل مستهدفه الان يتم دفن الشهداء
بهم من قبل الاهالي كما تشاهدون بعد تعذر
وصولهم الى اي مقبره او اي مكان لمباراتهم
الثر هؤلاء جثامين الشهداء وهؤلاء يحاولون
ايضا هنا فحر قبر جماعي لهم شهداء وبات
وجرحه
وهنا بندفن شه هذا
الحي دفنا الجثه اولادنا وهنا الجيران
كانوا مكلين عنا في البيت نفسهم منظار
الحسه وهنا بفحر لهم قبر جماعه عشان نهم
ناويهم الطراب متروق
الدنيا ونفخر لهم في المقابر حسبي الله
وانت نعم الوكيل شوف
شوفط هول الاطفال خط هولب مين هدول
خطيتهم ين ه خطيتهم الاطفال وشه وه الشباب
يلا هات هات ها
لسه يا عم في شه ت الضم فيهم تحت الضم لسه
يلين لسه يل
شهين امبارح مرميين بالشارع هذول من
امبارح لسه من الساعه 7 المقرب بالشارع
مرميين ولا اسعافات ولا ايات شي ولا اكل
ولا شرب ولا نيل هي مبسوطين هيك نا رايحين
نجيب كمان جرحه وفي شهداء كمان بدك تشوف
الشهدا في دفنا وفي هي رايحين نجيب جرحه
من بيتنا ه تعال افرجيك بيتنا اربع طوا في
البيوت ثلاث ايام في البيوت لا ميه ولا
شرب ولا اكل ولا طحين ولا حاجه فيش حاجه
عند الناس تاكل وتشرب فيلنا كيف المرضى
المرضى المرضى المرضى مش ين لا اسعب ولا
دفاع مدني الناس تن فدورها قاده يتقوا
الله على مقربه من هان على بعد 100 متر
تقريبا توج تتواجد الدبابات الاسرائيليه
هنا في هذه المنطقه وتدور اشتباكات ايضا
لكن هنا الاهالي يبادرون بمبادره فرديه
كما تشاهدون بانتشال جثامين الشهداء
ووضعها على هذه العربه تمهيدا لدفنها في
نفس
الحي
يعوا تعال
معان اع صاحب هذه الشاحنه هو بادر لنقل
الاصابات والبحث عن مكان لنقل لنقلها
بداخله هذه الاصابات منذ مساء الامس كما
تشاهدون هي اصابات فوق المتوسطه الان
ملقاه كما تشاهدون في هذا في هذا المكان
منذ مساء الامس ويبحثون عن مكانا لدفنه
ايش اللي صار طب ايش اللي صار عروس اربع
طوابق نزلوا عليه
عروسنا ل مش عارفين نوديهم مش عارفين كيف
نطعم الويل عارفين ايش نعمل عارفين ايش
نعمل ايش نعمل الاصبات منش امبارح الساعه
من بعد المغرب نزلت عمارتين على دورنا
اربع طوابق نزلوا علينا عمارتنا اربع
طوابق نزلت علينا فيش فيها حد يعني 100
نفر بسش فيها حد واصابات طعنا 20 من
اصابات متوسطه شايف خطيره مش متوسطه خطيره
في
مستشفى ايضا هذا طفل كما تشاهدون الان
اصيب بجروح بليغه وحروق بليغه لكن لا
يجدون مكانا منذ الامس ليكونوا ليتعالج
بداخ
الاال كما تشاهدون هنا جثامين الشهداء
ملقاه على الارض في استهداف الاحتلال
منزلا لعائله السويسي في منطقه ابو اسكندر
حمار
عباده صاروخ اطفال شهدا 30 40 شهيد تقريبا
ولسه في في الدار في الدوغ شهداء في
ناجحين عننا حوالي تقريبا 15 شهيد اطفال
بمر الورد بس هدفهم بدون سابق انذار او اي
شيء بدون ولا انذار ولا شيء انا شفت
الساروخ طاير من ورا وانا على الشباك وفي
الدار طلعنا لجري لقينا الدار واقع طلعنا
اصابات طلعنا شهداء اشلا مقطعين كم شهيد
تقريبا في الدار
يمكن في لاث دور يمكن 25
شهيد